hello and welcome to this video which
covers around 10 of the Tata Steel
tournament for 2017 and this round had a
couple of interesting decisive game so I
want to focus on those there were a
couple of drawers that looked quite
interesting in fact that yeah let's
focus on on the games that had a
decisive result let's talk it isn't
above the drawers though quickly that
wasn't really flying gear is a Dutch
duel and one of the super solid drawers
nothing much happened I think it's you
haven't really played them to save
opening and not much happened how
recreational cards and also not too
exciting harikrishna with white played
the the the rillo past four nights of
spanish four nights which is yeah kind
of it's extremely extremely difficult to
do something against a cousin tried
around a bit but yeah it was difficult
so we'll draw at the end al of x ii was
in fact quite interesting there were
some interesting moments at the end but
it ended in a draw maybe a lien or had
some chances but it's um it was a draw
and audubon lupinacci was a very
complicated game with some wild
complications um kind of clear right
complicated complications and there were
some clear chances Fadi want to win this
game but it was I guess yeah sometimes I
think additions are just too difficult
for human players and yeah at the end it
was it was a job so let's focus on the
decisive games we have kayaking white
playing and raking and we have a Italian
came with these three care very much in
fashion nowadays and I think we've seen
those kind of moves
yeah quite often and Drake in here
playing with a 5 this is an interesting
way of playing this I usually go a six
in those positions and always wonder if
this is the right approach as a five
does have some points I mean it prevents
any before moves and this in itself is
quite helpful so you don't get ya pushed
back on the queenside of course having
beacon b5 is not so nice but it probably
is the better option I really have to
look into this so all those moves look
super normal we should be six year
played the black and kayaking just yeah
ignores this basically and allow some
potential caption yeah this is what I'm
breaking did transferring into this kind
of setup is oftentimes I feel a bit more
comfortable for white because he has a
good control over d5 and white has more
space due to this control so I've always
reluctant to take there and get give
white this double porn still there's
nothing particularly wrong with it I'm
just saying it's not something that I
consider to too much of a problem for
why that he has the double pawn in fact
I think why doesn't mine it all yeah a
four is probably a good idea use the a
file some movers what you say a file is
probably the wrong way to put it but I
get rid of the a pawn and potentially
open the eighth home yeah so all this
looks at thinking they are the normal
fairly logical and we see now an
interesting idea by kayak and he plays
Knight age five and then breaking goes
back there was nothing wrong I believe
in
in simply and simply trading yeah like
this and maybe think about it at five
but 97 was the choice yeah and here i
don't know i probably would have tried
to avoid this position now that kayaking
goes for Queen g4 I mean with black I
probably would have liked to avoid that
yeah there's the main threat and the
only convenient way to handle this is to
to trade Queens and now I know it looks
funny like getting another double porn
but I think this is pretty nice here
those three pawns they give them why the
pretty good grip over the position and
give them some space advantage the pawns
are not weak I think this is quite okay
for white even though it's from the
northern advantage I think the key
moment comes a little bit later write a
five interesting forcing going to take
and now of course not GTX yeah GTX is
couch capturing towards the center but
much more interesting is to take with
the eeprom so that the night gets the
square now why doesn't mind this double
porn construction doesn't matter at all
and 94 now becomes an idea yeah black
stops that with the 1si that controls
the square with d5 and now we get this
situation and I think here it's a
critical moment black plays be formed
white eggs and now we tried to move
before and it seems that this is getting
black into some serious trouble group 88
was probably the better choice 888 the
bandage was looking at this pawn for
example one the ideas let's see eight
and so if we
just make normal looking something like
this then I'd see a for example 8 and
something like that that gets us back
the problem with this move deploys that
well why does not going to lose the pond
anytime soon he will keep the spasm and
it gives two important squares for the
night in particular if form I really
believe that black now is in some
trouble ok 5 and night comes back to
destroy that's a great square now and b5
this in turn secures the c6 square and
we will see that this is important why
it quickly gets a look there yeah and
you know the beep code is just dangerous
it's a it just is not it's not a good
position from black heathen in deep
trouble and I honestly believe it's hard
to save the position yeah i think that
move t4 really got black into huge
trouble he played 93 and now 92 and note
that this is a good square it's a safe
square can go to see form and the black
pawns they don't do all that much the
night he is stopping them very nicely
the B porn is dangerous can be 72 but
white manages to keep the important pawn
them yeah this is a winning position it
just requires good technical claim and
of course kayak it has that technique
now now we get the famous look behind
the pawn the best possible situation in
almost all cases if you have a passed
pawn the book belongs behind the pawn to
give it an extra boost so to say so the
pawn is just pushed forward and why does
can not worried about the Kings side
if the king is just a lot quicker to the
action b5 k and g 4 is the simple
simplest solution if black takes light
captures this and J now runs towards the
pawn and promoted and this is also not a
big difference look f 24 we got five gem
and white picks up everything so I'm
very clean win here for kayaking
arrogance and rakin it looked them like
black is ok if he is avoiding he's
avoiding this deform who kb eight I mean
I I think that he probably could have
done or could have solved his problems
more he is easier but here for example
of this f5 I think this is easier then
what he did but it was bad it just
required extreme precision now hear the
beep horn is a bit of a weakness and
after he has given up the pond he just
didn't manage to kill it back ok so we
inform the last World Championship
challenger next game and this is now
tough because I attend to show the most
interesting game at the end and it's
tough to attest to choose but I think I
probably go with this order we have the
game of the current tournament vida
Wesley is so plain white against
transfer water check and so goes for c4
and we can suppose into a cash in an
opening what Shaq plays Bishop e7 there
I mean yeah probably it is the right to
call the classical defends the most
solid defense and now an interesting
choice by the American player Queen to
see to this is some a little twist
compared to Castle
if white castles black will most likely
play the main line with the capture on
c4 and then we get probably Quincy to a
six a four or Quincy form which is the
are you be the main line of the Catalan
in itself Quincy tool is interesting
from a couple of reasons the main point
is that if black now wants to play in
the same way like taking and then opting
for a 6b five white has additional
options now and one idea is to take and
now after a six not to cancel but use
this move differently castling would be
just a transposition but white can play
the the immediate Queen c2 and wait for
black top 25 and use the temple
differently or you can play Bishop f4
most is interesting there's also the
movement BD through which I have played
in this position this tries to take this
with the night which would be very
comfortable it then it has to be said
that a position like this black has to
be very careful to go into because
long-term the bishop on g2 might prove
to be far more effective than the bishop
on cm8 castles rooty one Bishop f4
whines also quicker and development 22
is an interesting move the best defense
so black is what water shake played c5
now white can take on C fiber capsules
that was played and now lights is six
here the most common choice is actually
to take on d4 Knight takes and now black
has a has a choice you can play in this
very smooth 96 in 526 all those moves
are possible if I for example was played
by by vishy anand in a game and what
almond is whitish ex-boxer
what the shake is one of the main
seconds of the world champions the
former world champion so if I wouldn't
have been a surprise or this line wound
up in surprises watch it Shay place 96
and played so quickly so it's certainly
part of preparation yeah why 21 c 5
deform like ass grabbing space however
this leads to a position time that I
like for wise let's see what happened
through p1 sorry Avery first I forgot
that a three-fer getting this threaten
some black plays a five note that if you
take it he immediately then after before
it is a nice position White has chances
to ya put lots of pressure on the cornea
example like here you can go b5 and then
this is lacking a bit of protection a
five rupee 1e5 and now a very nice idea
93 is flight using the pin on the
default and after Bishop takes Knight d5
so the white light all of a sudden
managed to jump into d5 we have to first
see that black cannot take this piece
and here we have a double attack in a
way attacked attacked and queen takes is
answered with 95 and the maid threat and
simultaneously attacked queen on d5 is a
complete disaster for black he played
the move h6 that was necessary 95 was a
huge threat anyway okay should be true
still played very quickly by viruses so
the idea seems to be just to push before
on the queenside quickly getting an
attack going yeah and the water shake
now played a form looks very logical
however on to Bishop perform again
played immediately and why it seems to
be better
he took this 8x and we see that now the
84 pond is under pressure like 55 and
white took the bishop yeah now the
bishop sorry the night is hanging on d5
and goes to B form after which Queen d2
is the obvious move night went back
there is nothing else basically and now
before yeah in this position it looks it
doesn't look like much if you if you
check it first but if you look at this
for a little bit longer you recognize
that this position is difficult for
black the problems that black faces arm
the center this d 45 is it a little bit
unstable and d5 SRB five is always an
idea for white pushing the night away
and then e five would hang the a for
porn is a passer but also mostly a
weakness this pawn is pretty much
unsupported and which is the factor in
the game the white knight might come to
the 69 f 32 d2 to d4 to d6 and black
does not have much activity I believe
that this position is already quite
problematic it doesn't look like much
but I don't think like ian is very happy
here maybe you can improve now is
playing with bishop is six foot let's
have a look what water shake plate Queen
to e7 Queen be true this is a good move
it clears the square for the night route
it also prepares b5 potentially followed
by Queen to d4 and this is also what
happened in the game we should be false
played and now first rookie one it's a
good move preparing this covering e to
that you can move
I group the aid was played and now 92 as
mentioned you could argue that black
could take this night to prevent it but
i think this position is also quite
favorable for white note that he
wouldn't take with the bishop but very
likely with the pawn intending to play
at form the bishop would be much
stronger than the Black Knight here so
we have this regrouping with 92 and now
we should be six maybe he and III was an
idea simply to make it yeah more murky
after mum rocky work here I know but one
thing I do know that this position is
not good to be because after be five and
the backlight doesn't have a good square
went to be eight and now queen before
now is he weak and white has three pawns
basically against one combined with the
bishop this is now very very bad like I
don't think you can save this position
and it's really bad f5 and 93 going
towards a five and now the born on
descent was just taken looks a bit weird
but what is black supposed to play what
is he supposed to play why it wants to
take the a four paws and then put the
night on a five and windy seven
basically I am supposed to keep the
night on bh for the rest of the game
it's a complete disaster rename tix yeah
and so now place this replace the whole
game absolutely perfectly I mean every
move is just fought on route eight form
just ignoring that the bishop is
attacked because there is this fork no
it's not that so like does not have
anything else it takes you
and now has to play like that yeah this
position is a total and it's totally
lost if black now recaptures on d 7 then
why it starts to push the pawns they're
not something like that is just going to
be yeah and it's going to be a new queen
very soon in the game it took here yeah
okay take sticks and he calculated this
till the end now look see one it's quite
nice if that now captures this is very
easy so back to e6 and here white also
has a clean win with rook c8 j and at
the end b6 you cannot prevent the nice
jump and b7 leading to an end game a
piece of that was an extremely well
played game by so he got a nice position
out of the opening I mean this is here
very good opening prep he got this from
preparation basically and wise position
is quite quite more comfortable than
blacks it really black drifted into a
tough situation so quickly here this
position i think is very difficult for
like already yes to be super precise and
after he mr. I think this final
opportunity to play some D three-year to
just make it a bit more a bit long in
balance yeah after that I think here
after this and 98 clean before he's
basically lost so a super clean win form
you see the both number three labia
should be rose number three was there so
a very good tournament again he has an
extremely lucky game at the beginning
when he was completely lost against
report and wonders but he played
absolutely brilliantly the other games
so very good win let's look at the final
game and usually you see that I like
this game a lot so then if I show
something else as the final game that
must be a
with one bit so let's go for our
audience white game here against report
we have a queen vinian so the Hungarian
um player goes for a very solid opening
this time he plays the same variation of
the croods Indian that he had played in
that mention game against restless soul
report has a really nice position there
and then spoiling it so Bishop t2 Bishop
m6y and here the most normal moves are
would see one or two in situ I'm not
completely certain what was played in
them in the soul game from your book see
one I would need to look that up but one
of those aronia now place the move
Bishop v1 this is an extremely rare
continuation and I've at sounds like an
just a handful of games it's quite
uncommon the main idea seems to be to
simply prevent the Black Knight from
being able to take the bishop on d2 and
somehow forced like in to take on c3
okay the rupee eight was played green c2
and I know it sounds tough but I think
the next move already gets black into
huge problems and maybe it shows a
little bit I know the lack of experience
that report has with this positions I'm
and it's hard to sail it but that was
really is bad it's just bad he played t5
and we will see in the game why this is
a problem in general playing d5 in the
Queen's in ian is not uncommon but you
rarely allow this kind of this kind of
structure with taking and details it's
however mostly concrete problems that
arise here white goes 32 and now it's
again it's mostly technical concrete
play that gives black the problems now
and here black only has two moves to
check the the captures on the form if
you don't take on d4 now white will take
on f1 or play III and then take on you
for just being a full Center porn up so
black has to take in the game he took
with the bishop we can look at Queen
takes it doesn't seem to be much better
why takes on e4 with the night and
threatens night takes f6 check picking
out the bishop it's funny but the only
move that now does not lose immediately
is Bishop c6 bit of a sick looking move
when it's the only move that again does
not use immediately after Bishop c3
however White has the better chances
here as well for example after Queen
takes check and I take and now he fall
intending to switch the Queen over to
the Kings side like is under tremendous
pressure I think this position is very
likely also very bad so in the game he
did not take with the Queen but with the
bishop yeah and now aronia plays this
this whole game they're really really
nicely of course you can just take on
you for now and probably came claimed an
advantage but the minus q1 is also very
nice it just threatens now discoveries
with the night trapping it basically is
a bishop i mean and i use the spin so a
black now again has a limited choice he
can play the move f5 or move the Queen
basically after at five why this
immediately striking here because of
that pin for example after this [ __ ]
takes we should takes pawn takes and
clean takes white is threatening to to
just win this and then be a pawn out
with a winning position so black has to
can at least grab a porn but then this
is also looking very problematic from
black
it seems unlikely that is not going to
lose one of the greenside pawns the game
report played queen to c8 stepping out
of the default however here after night
takes and we see that if we look at the
board as a as two areas kings island
queens and just go get the Kings side on
the King side here there is just a black
king on g8 and the rukon yet there's
lots of stuff on the queenside here and
this is not defending currently White
has a couple of pieces that have
potential attackers the night of course
the Queen also wishes might come and
this Bishop might come this is a on the
coming attack now is mostly very
reminiscent of games by other kind we
had this quite often playing some
default position that looked at focused
on the queenside like hanging pawns or
an isolated pawn something like then all
of a sudden because the black player was
somehow bit ly on the queenside
defending he switched everything to the
King side and got a mating attack this
position is very difficult for like I
mean I know it sounds start and sounds
harsh but maybe you cannot save this
anymore it really is it seems difficult
to do and report please Bishop c5 the
bishop was hanging after all and now of
course aronian is not going for
something you have for something like 90
xe5 playing for a small pile of
strategic advantage this is a this is
something when you have to play for
checkmate anything else is just not the
purpose of the game so 95 let's just go
mate on h7 it's the idea yeah black um
has left after Mia event f5 probably
have to g6 looks
also pretty awful after something like
this where the White Knight is yeah
aiming to go to f6 why 84 note that here
the move 97 is simply not possible
because why this better developed it's
probably just totally also from black
and so f5 was played and now after the
trade Aronian activated the bishop here
on c3 yeah it's a it's a very nice
position black here and has to be now
extremely circumspect not to lose
immediately something like age 6 this is
pretty nice but still page six why
decisions of course going to take here I
can take here I can also check for again
this is probably probably strong we're
okay and black gets killed I mean why
does the checking with everything in or
alternatively okay something like that
is probably ending in a mate so aged six
does not work ninety-seven does not work
he played Bishop f8 at least getting the
bishop back to two more defensive
somewhat defensive position and now of
course every move should be powerful you
need to use the momentum so inform
breaking this open age 6 by report yeah
it's probably there's probably nothing
else you cannot just I mean f5 Hanks so
you have to do something and while
taking us out of the questions of age
six and now of course not some lousy
retreat let's check the most aggressive
moves aronian took one at five this is
strong and yeah again probably blackest
is beyond saving so what's going on here
can like take the night there is
actually what report did and I think
it's the best practical decision just
take the p
and hope that you survived somehow that
the opponent is doing something
something bad I'm after on take for
example why this just going to use all
the pieces something like that it's
extremely powerful you have to look at a
position like that for example and see
white is the piece down but all three
pieces are perfectly placed and are
attacking and this stuff is not doing
much but if not cannot put up any stiff
resistance here note that for example if
you move the sea pawn something that
rook e8 is totally paralyzing him you
don't necessarily have to mate
immediately here as you sometimes
probably can just yeah pippin him to
death yeah we should be fine or
something like that could be a deadly
pin in the game he took the night and
now alone Young played m6 very nicely
opening up this diagonal for the Queen
yeah again he tried the move c5 engines
point out that his six could be a bit a
bit tougher but at the end this is also
an extremely strong attack white needs
to use all pieces f4 is a good move
opening up everything and yes something
like that is a very nice end and black
has a hard time to move anything as 97
it's just going to be answered by Kenny
yeah but this so yeah what is supposed
to play Knight a six then f5 is going to
be the decisive move and black just get
killed ok I tried c5 after which again
air force plate using every single
like he has a roof black plate here and
now very nicely f5 yeah just getting the
second def porn into the game if black
now takes on f5 why this just going to
recapture threatening f7 and well this
move doesn't help and how do you stop f7
guess you don't you can take but then
like jiff sorry history five the screws
very nice takes check ok and black is
not going to last long he took this but
after the capture on e6 the white idea
cringes six hours of course very strong
that was covered by the Queen g2 now
attack the rook yeah black he has to
save that so 9 a-6 but this in turn
around 57 so very nice attacking play
Queen age five yeah there was Bishop e7
as well but this is also a bit too
strong now threatening to take two times
only seven with the new painting and
you're not going to save it Queen age 54
straight Garrigan 658 yeah and now that
there's a final check combination here
with rook takes f8 yeah and here no well
he actually still play the move after
Luke takes this route we have okay
winning easily and this is what report
plate can after Queen to everyone he
resigned there we have this finished
coming up
Jay and white is going to checkmate very
quickly so very nice attacking game here
by aronia and very much in the style of
eloquent and we have to really take note
that it feels very difficult to give
like some advice after he played d5 I
feel a bit reluctant to call this yeah
almost decisive which I don't really see
a huge improvement for black he would be
at least in severe trouble anyway even
if you try and try different moves so I
would win here for the minyan number one
yeah I hope you enjoyed the coverage for
around 10 the Thursday 26 is a rest day
and after that we have friday saturday
sunday as the final rounds and i'll be
back of course the coverage of those
three final round as well it looks great
now for so who's the point ahead of the
field he will probably probably win this
tournament it seems like he's unbeatable
in a way and if he doesn't do the game
it seems difficult for somebody to catch
them yeah thanks for watching bye bye